macarons chocolate bonbons fresh
strawberries and cream but the catches
they're all fake i may and i'm a faux
food artist
the most popular item in my shop is
definitely macarons i start off by
kneading the clay adding spritz of water
i'll spread the clay with a rolling pin
i then cut them into halves so i can
feed them into a clay maker i started
creating fake food four years ago when i
used to work at a bag and the artist in
me was hungry for creation
i'm a lover of food and crafts so fake
food was a common denominator i knew i
needed to turn this hobby into a
business when my tennessee dining table
was covered with cupcakes
i get my inspirations from the japanese
baked food culture and memories of
patisserie shops in france where
desserts decorated the displays like
high-end fashion
because there isn't a textbook how to
make fake food the challenge is to
search for materials and methods on my
own
i think each fake food artist keeps
their methods secret so
i gather hints from crap videos and
blogs
it's rewarding when you finally find a
way to make something out of nothing
after the paint dries i use a glue gun
to add the filling
here i'm using white for vanilla
i also have milk chocolate dark
chocolate and caramel fillings
meringue peaks are one of my favorites
to make
real or fake the key to a perfect
barangay is to achieve a light airy
softness and to get those signature
peaks
first i turn the clay into small pieces
this will allow the clay to soak the
water faster
i add glue and mix until getting a silky
consistency with a rubber spatula this
will help create the peaks
then i use a hand mixer until i get a
smooth fine mirroring a texture
i pipe the clay through a star tip onto
a baking sheet
two to three days later when dry i add
the finishing touches
today i'm dipping them into chocolate
and adding sprinkles of course i'll fake
i think strawberries are the hardest but
most rewarding to make they add a pop of
color and look beautiful on cakes
once i prepped the clay i measured them
into about .4 ounce pieces and yes i
have strawberry sizes small to large
with a set weight i then place the clay
on a flower nail and mold it into a
strawberry shape
then i add the seeds using a needle tip
shaped like a teardrop
the clay is soft so i need to be very
careful not to lose the strawberry shape
after three to four days the
strawberries are ready for painting
for finishing touches i will add gloss
for that perfect shiny juicy look
now the fun part for today
i'm going to be making the alphabet tea
for tasty
i start off painting the two wood panels
brown to make chocolate cookies
i glue on wood pieces that will hold the
two layers in place
then i start to outline the cake with
thick cream using a round piping tip
once that is finished i place the top
cookie layer
then to support the farm i drive screws
in with a power drill
now the movement that we're all waiting
for it's time to decorate i prep the
surface with glue so the clay will have
a strong bond
i covered a cookie with generous amounts
of cream
assembling is like a painting process
choosing a color thinking of a theme
a message
today i wanted to express the fun
vibrant and whimsy that tasty brings to
food
i feel our love for sweets is a
universal language
it's like celebrating that special
occasion surrounding a cake with loved
ones
and voila
we have our fake cookie cake
i hope you had fun watching and getting
a little glimpse into the world of fake
food happy april fool's day
oh yes
you